[Music]
so are you single right now are you
dating anybody I'm kind of in purgatory
right now okay monix am i yeah I'm kind
of I'm kind of I'm not just saying I'm
kind of like in the middle I'm open to
new ideas I've been dating but I'm not I
pull back a little bit I'm not in the
place where I want everything to be
rushed and I don't want the big white
dress and the big I wanted to rush me
down the aisle because what happens is
when you're in the public and you date
everyone's like you fat she's happy she
found love again she's happier than
she's ever been and that's part of the
message to not need to not need a man if
you choose to be with someone that's
great but to not need that to complete
you it's not Jared we're not living in
the Jerry Maguire movie and no man is
going to complete me I complete myself
that message inspired Bethany's new
collaboration with Dress for Success Sun
intervention initiative calls be strong
I approached them and asked them if I
could do a charity within their charity
called be strong I have never felt so
connected to something because I've
never really thought about the pain that
women go through I think that it's my
job to really tell women to not be
dependent upon a man and to go get your
own and not that there's anything wrong
with marriage or being a partner with
someone but you never know what's going
to happen and you don't know how people
are going to act and women have to have
their own lives is getting married
something that you could see happen to
get in the future um it's not something
that I couldn't see it's just not
something that I do see right now it's
not it's not on my mind that's funny
because I watched some of the women on
my show horse angle running around like
it's their job every night going out
wanting to meet men men
and it's kind of the whole entire cast
actually you said to tweet out about
about thinking about adopting a little
girl here in New York City that was
abandoned at a train station are you are
you looking to have more children
I was totally serious and I did have a
lawyer look into it and they said
there's nothing you can do you won't be
able never be able to get that child and
it was very it was upsetting hopefully
she was with another family member I
think they were trying to help the
grandmother get into the country so but
adding you know adding another child is
something that's not out of the question
it's not out of the question it's just
if I see a shot the stork dropped the
child off at the front door I'm not
gonna give it away
I'll keep it you know if somebody drops
a basket off you know
[Music]
you